I I do the um
lots of notes and beats and like try and
figure out the story before typing
because I find that typing is really
horrible
um and just it just hurts
um your body
and your mind to sit in front of a blank
screen and now what's next I like to
just have the whole plan out in front of
me and no and basically how I write I'll
start with the beginning and the end I
just want to really like visually or
like just something that I think it's
like this would be a cool way to end a
movie and there's a cool last image for
an audience to see this would be a cool
first image and this would be a cool way
to open a film and then I'll start and
then I'll put in some scenes throughout
I think this would be a great scene and
then eventually when I've got enough of
these scenes or sequences then lazily
just glue them all together with some
sort of connecting scenes but that's it
really that's sort of what that's my
style and when I know what it is then I
can write really fast